- All right, y'all, we have time
for one more uplifting story.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
Police officers often find unique ways
to connect with the community,
but probably none are as unique
as this officer from Maryland.
("Star Spangled Banner")
(audience clapping)
So beautiful.
Officer Alexander Strachan
of the Prince George's
County Police Department
has been playing violin all his life,
beautifully, might I add.
He says music is a
bridge to the community.
I could not agree more.
Let's get him in here everybody.
All right, Officer
Strachan, how you doing?
(audience cheering)
- Hi Kelly.
It's so nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you as well.
Wow, first of all, you
have a beautiful smile.
My goodness.
Well, you only recently.
- Well, thank you.
- Yeah, you're welcome.
You only recently joined the
police force, is that right?
- Yes, I joined about two years ago.
It's been such an honor to be a officer
for the Prince George's County Police.
I've had the opportunity
to be able to play violin
in uniform, so it's so
neat to be able to help
be a bridge for the community.
I get to go, and that was
at the Wellness House.
I get to play different
communities and charities
and represent the police department.
Maybe we'll go in nursing homes
and it's so cool because
people see the gun and badge
and think, "Well, what's going on?"
And they see me playing the violin
and they're like, "Oh, this is so cool."
So, it's an amazing
opportunity and such an honor.
I'm incredibly blessed.
- It's a cool way for kids, especially,
to see law enforcement
in a different light.
So how did you, was it your grandparents?
Is that what started you
in the nursing homes?
- Yes.
So my grandmother, she had
Alzheimer's and breast cancer
and music was something
that brought her back to me
despite the fog of the Alzheimer's.
And it was that amazing connection
that I could have being
able to play music for her,
especially the day before she passed away.
And I wanted to continue
that work in nursing homes
and for people in hospice as well.
Playing for terminally ill children
and adults by the bedside.
- That is such a cool thing, man.
You're so rad.
Can we hear a little
bit of "Amazing Grace"?
- Absolutely, it's one of
my grandma's favorites.
- I love it, mine too.
("Amazing Grace")
Wow, I love the vents, the slight vents.
Man, that's so good.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Officer Strachan.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheering)
That's not all though.
Our season long partner Pilot
Pen, the makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
are inspired by your
dedication to your community
and the memory of your grandmother.
So they're gonna write
you a check for $1,000
on your behalf to the Wellness House
of Annapolis.
- Thank you so much.
- Which is dedicated to serving families
who have been touched by cancer.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Have a blessed day.
And thank you to everybody,
all our guests this hour:
Hannah Waddingham, Reid Scott,
Garrett and Emily Coffman.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.